un plan pour lutter contre la vétusté
des lycées l'objectif de ce plan
d'urgence pour les lycées franciliens
construire de nouveaux lycées et rénover
les autres alors ce plan d'urgence avait
déjà été adoptée en 2010 est on le
rappelle par la région ile de france
il s'étend sur la période de 2017 à 2027
et prévoyez notamment un budget de 5 1
milliards d'euros
parmi lesquels 4,1 milliards alloués aux
investissements notamment dans les
équipements sportifs dans les
aménagements liés à l'accueil des
personnes en situation de handicap et
aussi dans la construction le milliard
d'euros restants est prévu pour la
maintenance et à dire dans les besoins
quotidiens
parmi les autres objectifs on trouve la
création aussi de 21 mille six cent
nouvelles places d'ici 2027
alors ce plan initial voté donc en 2017
a dû être révisée pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce qu'ils se basent sur
une étude menée par l'institut paris
région en 2016 une étude qui a été mise
à jour en 2020 qui montre une
augmentation supplémentaire de 65 mille
cinq cents lycéens public et d'ici 2030
par rapport aux estimations de 2016 pour
pallier le problème le plan a été révisé
et prévoit la création de neuf mille
places supplémentaires dans les lycées
franciliens en plus de celles déjà
prévues
résultat 30 mille six cent nouvelles
places devraient être créés d'ici 2027
une opération qui nécessite donc un
budget supplémentaire qui s'élève à 900
millions d'euros portant ce plan
d'urgence révisé à 6 milliards d'euros